they're camping out in an airport but
they're not going anywhere around 500
people have found shelter in an old
hangar here they hide from militias who
hunt down Muslims on a gazillion is
Ilona they broke into our house
threatened us and started killing they
even ate the flesh of their victims Yolo
muy this on the economy was so we had no
choice but to flee to the airport the
buggy on a visit if you don't listen to
the night apart thousands have managed
to get out of the country from here the
people left behind are hoping that
soldiers or aid organizations will help
them escape the biggest Muslim district
in the capital bhangi is deserted
100,000 people used to live here now
there are just a few hundred this man's
wounds are still fresh the result of an
ambush by a group of men Jim SE retrouve
suddenly there were five men armed with
machetes are me blush a machete I had no
weapons it and could not defend myself
as a throne I was under shocked on their
good day shock Muslims in the city
saying they've been abandoned even by
French peacekeeping troops who are
supposed to protect the civilian
population la inca public the jury
they're incapable of implementing their
own policies imagino new cingular
marantz cannot even provide security in
our neighborhood in the middle of bunge
suit in the security most of the
remaining residents have already loaded
up their belongings onto trucks they
think leaving is the only certain way to
escape death